be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so continuing our discussion on Jean
Grey with the last video establishing
her character's publication history as
being lackluster and as she was
routinely shown to have been the x-men's
weakest member constantly requiring the
efforts of her teammates in both
training simulations and real-world
conflicts after taking over this series
with uncanny x-men issue number 94
because Claremont looked to the x-men
lineup as a series that could expand the
motives and ideologies of his individual
members Jean Grey was used as an
experimental platform in an effort to
bolster her status within both the x-men
team proper and the Marvel Universe as a
whole to this end with x-men issue
number 98 going into issue number 101
Claremont orchestrated his reinvention
of Jean within the pages of the prelude
to the Phoenix saga centering on the
introduction of Stephen Lang as an
anti-mutant fanatic who had been
assigned the Sentinel project following
the defeat of ball of art Trask during
the climax of the three-part story a
handful of the original x-men had been
kidnapped by Lang and taken to a
satellite orbiting the Earth during
which time Cyclops Jean and the
remaining members of the team launched a
rescue mission coming into conflict with
both the traditional sentinels as well
as a new model designed to mimic the
original x-men team and both appearance
and abilities where the X random cells
were successful in defeating Lane during
their journey back to earth the group
was bombarded with cosmic radiation
incapacitating all the other members and
piloting the shuttle back herself during
its reentry and while succumbing to the
lethal effects of radiation gene had
telepathically reached out to the
Phoenix force which in turn offered a
pact of sorts as it was explained Jean
was quite literally walking the line
between life and death and that if she
had survived and been allowed to return
to Earth she likely would have fallen
into a catatonic state
due in part to her minds inability to
cope with the pain that she was
experiencing as well as the shock of
nearly dying offering to bond itself
with Jean the original intention of
Claremont was to have her cure to go
forward as a wholly new be with her
abilities of telepathy and telekinesis
enhanced to cosmic levels accepting the
entity's offer and arriving back on
earth after the shuttle had landed jean
emerge from the water declaring herself
to have been reborn as the Phoenix using
this as a jumping-off platform with
issue number 101
Claire MA began to both expand on the
x-men's place within the marvel
most as well as introduce a host of new
concepts on the cosmic level but largely
confined to the x-men as a team with its
first piece coming to fruition as the
Shiar whether Empire existed as an
amalgamation of various races coming
together in swearing allegiance to the
imperial crown Claremont also
established that the Shiar functioned to
ensure the safety of the m'kraan crystal
a physical stone operating as the nexus
point for all realities of the
multiverse however with the Shiar were
lured akin losing his sanity and
developing a lust for power his younger
sister lilandra had come to the
conclusion that they can look to secure
the powers of the m'kraan crystal to not
only rule the universe but take over all
other realities as well making contact
with Charles Xavier and the x-men owing
to the fact that the earth had some of
the most powerful beings in the universe
because the Phoenix force was a
protector of life and tied directly to
the crystal itself the Phoenix saga
unfolded and concluded with Jean and the
x-men joining forces with the Shiar the
newly introduced starjammers led by
Cyclops his father and a host of other
beings all of whom battled the forces of
de Ken culminating in the m'kraan
crystal cracking Claremont added a bit
of history to the Marvel Universe and
stating that if the m'kraan crystal were
to shatter entirely the multiverse
itself would end after which the crystal
would reform and initiate a recreation
of all things while this bit of
storytelling would become a cornerstone
of Marvel comics and remain part of
future stories which would reveal that
the earth-616 universe was actually the
seventh incarnation as a result of the
previous multiverses destruction
bleeding into the birth of Galactus in
terms of the main event the Phoenix
soccer proper saw the m'kraan crystal
cracked wide akin and healed by the
Phoenix resulting in the multiverse
being saved and the x-men returning to
Earth using this to beef up the team's
individual stories as well as wrap
around to the conclusion of the Phoenix
epic were the events between the
conclusion of the Phoenix saga and
uncanny x-men issue number 108 and the
beginning of the Dark Phoenix saga an
uncanny x-men issue number 192 saw
Cyclops spending time with his father
and a love triangle forming between Jean
Scott and Wolverine Claremont began to
set the stage for his finale by
introducing the International
clandestine organization called the
Hellfire Club
originally led by Sebastian Shaw and
composed of Emma Frost Donald Pierce
Harry Leland and tentative initiate
jason wyngarde
Hellfire Club operated behind-the-scenes
manipulating the financial and political
sector to both remain hidden and ensure
the success of their plans to dominate
the world taking notice of Jean Grey due
to Emma Frost's omega-level telepathic
powers and viewing Jean as a potential
member who could be used to further
their schemes jason wyngarde was tasked
with manipulating her five senses
stealing jean away from the x-men and
inducting her into their ranks as proof
of his capabilities in being an asset
however with the conclusion of the
Phoenix saga seeing Jean give herself
fully to the entity as well as Phoenix
itself having never experienced the full
range of human emotions the
manipulations of jason wyngarde
exposed the Phoenix force to a multitude
of concepts including lust rage NB and
revenge becoming enthralled and
overwhelmed the goal of Chris Claremont
came to his fruition and that were the
Phoenix akka represented rebirth the
Dark Phoenix saga intended to represent
corruption and fall from grace losing
all sense of sanity and stepping into
the role of a villain after overpowering
the mind of jason wyngarde and sending
him into a catatonic state Jean took to
the universe consuming a son and
destroying its solar system killing an
entire culture in the process drawing
the attention of the Shiar who viewed
the rogue entity as a threat to the
universe itself the Dark Phoenix saga
reached its climax when the x-men
suppress the power of the Phoenix force
and invoked the shiaas tradition of
trial by combat facing off against the
Imperial Guard with the x-men being
overwhelmed entirely and the Phoenix
force working loose Colossus was able to
launch an attack assaulting Jean and
restoring her sanity temporarily during
which time she informed Cyclops that the
only way to spare his life and the lives
of the team was to sacrifice herself
activating a Kree weapon left behind
after their experiments on the Inhumans
gene was atomized completely and erased
from existence that said where Claremont
had intended for the Dark Phoenix saga
to conclude with Jean being depowered
leaving the x-men and forming a family
with Cyclops because the college code
was still a major part of the industry
albeit with more and more publishers
ignoring the rules the idea of
punishment for evil deeds was still a
major concept which could not be ignored
this combined with the strict editorial
policies of Jim shooters editor-in-chief
resulted in the death of Jean and
Cyclops abandoning the
continuing to carry out is ending as he
envisioned chris claremont introduced
Madeline prior a woman who was for all
intents and purposes identical to Jeanne
in terms of memories and physical
appearance using the emotional state of
Scott Summers as a means to bring the
two together and bear a child who would
go on to become cable the other half of
this equation came in the form of both
fan feedback and continued editorial
mandates from shooter covered in 2012
article by the Austin Chronicle title
Chris Claremont dead should mean dead
because the Phoenix and Dark Phoenix
saga is were so well received these
stories combined with the overall works
of Clement had catapulted the x-men team
to the front of Marvel's lineup
outselling all other titles by a margin
of 3 to 1 looking to capitalize on fan
demand by launching a new series titled
x-factor under the writing of Louise
Simonson Jim shooter looked at C Jean
Grey returned to the landscape while
also ensuring the continuity of her
character considered to be one of the
most controversial retcons in the
history of comics Clemens hand was
essentially forced requiring him to
establish that after having reached out
to the Phoenix force while piloting the
shuttle back to earth genes physical
body was placed in stasis at the bottom
of Jamaica Bay while the Phoenix took on
her form and acted in her stead as a
result the events of the Phoenix and
Dark Phoenix Tigers had their value
stripped away in that gene herself had
not risen to prominence and fallen from
grace and instead the events themselves
were entirely in the hand of the Phoenix
force to this end fans had found
themselves absolutely livid and feeling
betrayed believing that their journey
with Jean Grey was all for nothing
while this didn't directly affect the
sales of the x-men title owing in part
to Claremont's writing style and the
fact that fans still had a host of other
characters who were relatable and
enjoyable his retcon among other issues
led to a continued dislike of Jim
shooter as Marvel's editor-in-chief that
being said because the landscape was set
for Jean to return an x-factor issue
number one
Madeleine Pryor was not written out of
the picture so much as she remained in
the background leading into the events
of cables timeline and the future of
Earth as it was ruled by apocalypse
while you can learn this information in
my video about cable himself Jean
Cyclops angel Iceman and beast
maintain their own x-factor title under
the writing of Louise Simonson routinely
crossing over with the x-men team during
this time Louise Simonson began to flesh
out the backstory
Jeane even further focusing on our
sister the rise in anti-mutant
sentiments the idea of cyclops producing
a son with madeline and the introduction
of Rachel summers as a time-displaced
daughter of Scott and Jean from the Days
of Future past all of which was written
in a manner that depicted Jean catching
up on everything she had missed with the
stories of Louise Simonson receiving
critical acclaim for their depth and
focus some of which rivaled the works of
Chris Claremont the continued rise of
the excellence popularity saw a
wholesale reformation of both x-factor
and x-men taking place in 1991 with
x-men vol 2 issue number one both teams
were merged into a singular group but
split into two factions referred to as a
gold and blue teams initially coming
under the control of Chris Claremont as
writer and Jim Lee as artists both of
whom had vacated their positions within
Marvel Comics by issue number 20 this
time period saw a paradigm shift to dark
& high-octane stories following the
success of fight Miller's Dark Knight
Returns remaining within the pages of
uncanny x-men under the writing of John
Byrne and later by Scott Liddell in
truth jeans time in the post Claremont
era saw her taking a back seat amidst
the surge of x-men universe expansions
including the former New Mutants now
operating as x-force the introduction of
psylocke and marvel presents Weapon X
detailing the story of Wolverine
while events like the onslaught saga in
gene learning of Charles hidden love
affair for her as well as the marriage
of Scott and Jean in 1994 is uncanny
x-men issue number 308 stand out as
important parts of her character on the
whole the damage of the Phoenix and Dark
Phoenix saga continued to linger and
that while she wasn't reviled by fans
the magic had essentially been lost as a
result Jean found herself falling
rank-and-file with the rest of the team
going into June of 2001 with a launch of
new x-men orchestrated by
editor-in-chief Joe Quesada and written
by Grant Morrison in an effort to beef
up the failing title following the near
collapse of the comic book industry in
the late 1990s the style of Morrison
took a more liberal approach focusing on
the team assuming the roles of teachers
to a new generation of mutants at the
Xavier Institute while dealing with
their own personal issues relationships
and dealing with the newly emerging Pro
and anti mutant political sentiments at
the same time this series also saw the
return of genes telekinesis re-emergence
of her ability to tap into the powers of
the Phoenix force her assumption of the
duties
headmistress of the Xavier Institute and
the failing ever mayor's to Cyclops
following a psychic affair with Emma
Frost remaining on as writer for 41
issues during his four-year run Morrison
blended the writing style of Claremont
with his own focusing on the individual
members but also casting aside virtually
all classic villains and instead
introducing new individuals like us and
Renova alongside her massacre of 16
million mutants on the island of Genosha
considered one of the best runs if not a
bit polarizing to fans of more
traditional stories with the exception
of genes reaction to scott psychic
affair with Emma Frost and her death at
the hands of magneto masquerading as
horn on the whole she remained a
backseat character fighting various
villains and instructing a new age of
mutants with all manner of appearances
while Morrison's time concluded with the
story here comes tomorrow depicting an
alternate reality where Cyclops chose
not to run the Xavier Institute
alongside Emma following the death of
Jean the story of morrison black nearly
all of his writings was left to the
interpretation of the reader much to the
chagrin of existing fans who saw closure
to his time on the title revisiting
these concepts during his time as writer
of new x-men following Morrison's
departure writer Chuck Austin
established Jean as having stepped into
the role of the white Phoenix of the
crown existing in an ambiguous manner
described as performing surgery on the
universe using her powers to reach back
in time and influence Scott into running
the school alongside Emma and preventing
the here comes tomorrow timeline
having said that while Morrison's run
did contain a finite conclusion the
issue faced by fans was that there had
been a 150 year gap between the death of
Jean at the hands of zone and her
re-emergence as the white Phoenix of the
crown during the events of here comes
tomorrow
as a result readers were largely left
scratching their heads
owing to the fact that chuck Austin's
work treated the concept as if it had
already existed as well as feeling a
little irritated at the idea that Jean
had not received a proper send-off
looking to fill the holes left by the
Morrison Austin confusion as well as the
mess that came with the x-men reloaded
initiative which focus on relaunching
and rebranding the x-men related titles
in 2005 under the writing of Greg pack
Phoenix and song returned to the concept
of jeans death and a relation to the
white Phoenix of the crown centering on
the Shiar Empire resurrecting the
Phoenix which in turn resurrected Jean
Grey
in an effort to prevent the Phoenix
force from seizing control of her and
leading to a second incarnation of the
Dark Phoenix Jean had sought to have
wool Vern kill her and confine her body
and ice both of which proved to be
unsuccessful depicting the Phoenix as a
self-aware cosmic entity which looked to
return to its darker nature and continue
experiencing human emotions after
merging with Jean who succeeded in
taking control of the Phoenix the story
ended with the now iconic scene of
Jeanne offering her goodbyes to Scott
providing one of only a handful of
instances where by marvelous killed a
character without bringing them back
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and the next
discussion we have about Jean Grey will
be all-new all-different Jean and will
actually tie in to the events of civil
war and what it means with Jean Grey
appearing in the story but with that
being said I will catch you guys on her
peace